we are indeed with Tate of abrahamian
tatev back to back victories for you how
do you feel right now I feel great
the energy levels are up you're not
feeling tired at all uh no I don't feel
tired and we have one more game and
today off so this is going really well
so far what was uh the strategy going in
this game
um
I didn't really have a any specific
strategy I just thought
um I I wasn't
um
and I played this line I thought if we
play the end game with the car road then
I'll just play like a long game and I
thought in a long game I can do better
than her absolutely a lot of things
happen in this game they got through the
critical moments because it wasn't as
easy yeah so if we go once yeah if you
keep going forward she decided to avoid
the end game with AC4 I kind of thought
she might do that yes if we keep going
so here here
so I thought Queen v36 my position
should be good like her Bishop's locked
in
but then we keep going and then things
get a bit complicated
maybe H4 is unnecessary I don't know I
like H4 take a look at that because like
I don't really want to go H5 because H5
G5 I don't think it's good for me
because my D5 font is hanging and then
she went this bishop design Bishop D3
Queen V6
and I feel like yeah somewhere around
here how did you assess this end game
I thought I still should be good but
she has some concrete play like she goes
like 96 95 maybe get a bishop and um
yeah I played Rook C1 because night
before is coming Knight D6
yeah and here I got a bit stuck because
I wasn't sure which pieces I'm supposed
to exchange because obviously I want to
leave her with this D7 Bishop but I
don't know which of my Bishops I should
be exchanging whenever she plays Knight
one yeah so I went uh age five and then
I was thinking Knight F5 even
immediately I wasn't here I was thinking
Bishop G5 but I'm not 100 sure it works
okay I guess not
yeah but okay it's not yeah
j7 and it's yeah yeah and then but okay
I'm like okay she still has a bad Bishop
but I think we're exchanging too much
absolutely but again I'm not sure if I
should take on F5 or let her take on E3
and
in this position it seems take take and
perhaps you can actually go for this
hey continue taking okay so this way I'm
just kidding yeah this is another thing
I consider okay I'll go the other way so
give up my lights yeah I mean it makes
us to give up my lights go to Bishop in
the structure of course and I guess once
she goes to F7 you also have ideas
six perhaps
um she went for King F7 yeah here I tell
them yeah so here's uh probably felt her
position is getting worse well they need
to do something with tactically it
doesn't work out
and then so I went upon
and you guys got this position yeah but
here
three four she was getting some counter
chances against your king yeah and I
think were you concerned at all at this
point no I mean I calculated this and I
think her King is also a bit sketchy but
she does have to yeah I mean she
obviously she has some play and then
here I'm gonna take on C7 because yeah
rookie seven so I exchange it for 93
first exchange of Bishops and I feel
like here maybe things could have come
better for me so she checked I want can
give four which I think is okay yes
yeah no uh after this it felt the
transition was quite good perhaps here
at this point
after rotates B3 Bishop to E3 perhaps
yeah I thought about it going into this
Rook end game but okay through again
game seven
and then take on E3 I would assume is
the idea and play two versus one and but
okay two versus one another again that's
not an easy decision to make right
because I thought the scent came even
with the bishop like her Pawn looks kind
of dangerous because her Bishop's
covering B2 and I think she could have
played it better she like just let me
have a lot so she pushed down the board
but yeah she could have gone Bishop C3
here I think or maybe even King C4
instead of King E6 I mean okay during
the game it kind of looks scary I mean I
understand my pond is running but if she
can't give up her bishop and like this
one runs I don't know after a king to E4
yeah
maybe my assessment is not right but
yeah and here I've I don't know I just
kind of missed something I thought this
was just easy for me and then I started
playing and something so it's even
Bishop C3 check King I thought I'm
queening my opponent and I didn't oh
Bishop H6
oh that was my move and then I forgot to
play it the space no Bishop Basics
immediately and I'm just threatening
just the rubbish basics
that's so
just broke the G1 and then just came to
F5 yeah now she can't move Bishop takes
before he's coming
yeah this one is at the end of my game
was actually really nice because I set
up a little truck because I was also
getting low on time now I don't think oh
my God no I think I did yeah she did but
with this move King to D5
yeah I think I have to go maybe we
should
Rook before Rook F2 wow
that if still after that she did not
believe it
we have a lot of people love it's a full
Lobby full of players Tade thank you
very much for joining us congratulations
back-to-back victories thank you good
start torment we'll see you tomorrow